dernière question sur un autre projet de
loi qui a été adopté cette semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale le projet loi a
censé accélérer à les énergies
renouvelables le texte a été adopté
notamment avec les voix des députés
socialistes ça prouve qu'il peut y avoir
des alliances entre la majorité
présidentielle et la gauche pas
forcément qu'avec la droite et écoutez
ce projet de loi il a effectivement été
exercée c'est un exercice de
co-construction parlementaire comme on
l'a fait d'ailleurs au Sénat je rappelle
que le Sénat avez voté quasi unanimement
ce projet de loi à l'Assemblée nationale
de groupe liott et le Parti socialiste
pourtant dans l'opposition parce qu'il
croit vraiment que les Français et ils
entendent la demande des élus locales de
faire plus d'énergie renouvelable et
bien ils se sont investis dans ce texte
ils ont apporté des enrichissements et
nous avons pu effectivement trouver un
accord sur ce texte avec ces deux
groupes un compromis sera possible avec
le Sénat pour négocier une version
commune du texte chacun aborde la CMP
dans un esprit de co-construction comme
nous l'avons fait depuis le début de ce
texte et avec surtout intérêt général
des Français Chevilly au corps l'intérêt
aussi des collectivités locales oui nous
pouvons trouver un texte abouti qui
conviendra à tout le monde mais cela
suppose de sortir de la posture
politique merci beaucoup
à mes questions
[Musique]